hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar titled
hemoglobin a1c
the hidden factors biological
interferences
my name is david sacks and i'll be your
moderator today
today's educational webinar is presented
by lab roots
and brought to you by savior
incorporated
before we begin i just want to mention
that
i would like to encourage the audience
to participate by submitting questions
at any time
during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation
there are two speakers today the first
speaker is dr john higgins an associate
professor
at harvard medical school his title
is the hidden factors biological
interferences
red blood cell age and then when he's
finished his talk i
as a senior investigator at the nih will
speak my title is the impact factor
importance of variant detection
in hemoglobin a1c measurement and at the
end
of my talk there'll be time for
questions and answers
so without further ado i'd like to
introduce dr john higgins
thank you dr sachs for the nice
introduction the title of this
presentation
is the hidden factors biological
inferences
red blood cell age what i'd like to tell
you about in the next 20 minutes or so
is the effect of red blood cell age on
hemoglobin a1c
let's start just by reminding ourselves
why we're measuring a1c in the first
place
and that's because a1c tells us about
mean glucose variation
you can see from this plot which was
taken from a publication
related to the dcct trial in 2002
that as average glucose increases a1c
increases so a1c tells us a whole lot
about a patient's
recent average glucose level
what you can also see though is that
there's quite a bit of scatter around
that regression line
so while the trend is certainly there
the average
increase in average glucose leads to
increasing a1c
there's another source of variation that
we can't quite explain
if we look at data from another study
the a1c
derived average glucose study by david
nathan and colleagues
we can see a similar scatter around the
regression line
what the regression line allows us to do
is to tell patients with a hemoglobin
a1c of 7
that their recent average glucose is
about 154 milligrams per deciliter
but if we zoom in on this slide and we
look at
the individual measurements for all the
patients who had a1c measurements of
seven percent
we can see that there's actually quite a
bit of variation in their average
glucose
there's one individual there with the
green arrow who had an average glucose
of 132
another individual with the yellow arrow
who had an average glucose of 186
but yet if anyone sees used to guide
their treatment both of them will be
treated the same because their a1cs were
both
seven percent we what we'd like to
understand
is what causes this non-glycemic
variation in a1c
and and that's the topic of this
presentation
so first i'd like to provide some of the
evidence suggesting that red blood cell
age variation
can alter a1c independent of glucose
and then i'll i'll discuss a few common
clinical scenarios where red blood cell
age does seem to vary
and lastly i'll spend most of the time
discussing
some evidence that suggests that that
red blood cell age variation
may be the dominant source of
non-glycemic variation for a1c
and at some point in the future it might
be able it might be possible to adjust
a1c
for red cell age variation and end up
with an even more accurate estimate of
average glucose
using a1c
well i'm going to be spending the next
in the next little while talking about
how we can improve a1c about its
shortcomings but before i get started
i just want to remind everyone that a1c
is actually one of the best clinical
tests
because of the high prevalence of
diabetes with hundreds of millions of
people worldwide
suffering from diabetes and the high
rates of morbidity and mortality
associated with the disease
the fact that a1c has allowed us to
improve
diagnosis and management of diabetes
means that it has reduced morbidity and
mortality
probably as much as any other lab tests
we have available
so those figures there are showing the
high rates of cardiovascular risk
among diabetics as well as the high rate
of retinopathy
leading to blindness and what a1c's
enabled us to do
is to lower those rates of morbidity
now while a1c is a great test it does
have some shortcomings
and there is room for improvement this
recent study from pearlman and
colleagues reinforces what we saw on the
dcct plot
and the adag plot that while there's
clearly
a linear uh trend between increasing
mean glucose and increasing a1c
there's also quite a bit of scatter
around that regression line
and we're going to make errors when we
infer average glucose
from a1c so let's review some of the
the evidence for a role for rbc age
variation
as we said from the beginning
the recent glucose concentration
determines a1c
and there's there's solid evidence that
rbc aged
variation and variation in the mean red
cell age which i've shown here is mrbc
there's strong evidence that the mrbc
also influences a1c
so we can do that by comparing the
effects of
increasing glucose and increasing red
cell age at the same time
the schematic shows that when glucose is
high
following the steep black line if we
wait longer
the a1c will become much more elevated
and when glucose is low time will
continue to have an effect although
the effect is more shallow
there's evidence both in vitro and in
vivo for this relationship for effects
of both glucose
and time on
the in vitro evidence comes from
latavinsky and colleagues who cultured
red blood cells
in uh different concentrations of
glucose
the red x's correspond to conditions
where glucose was high
and when they allowed the red cells to
uh to incubate longer in the solution
the a1c increased and it equals
increased quite quickly the blue x's are
when the glucose concentration was lower
and the the a1c continued to increase
but it was
did not increase at quite the same rate
robert cohen and colleagues found a
similar pattern in vivo
they used viotim to label red cell red
blood cells both from diabetic patients
and non-diabetic patients
and in the diabetic patients who would
tend to have a higher glucose
concentration
we can see that as the mean of the age
of the red cells
increase the a1c increase and similarly
for the diabetics
as the as the mean age of red cells
increase the a1c increase
so these these two panels convince us
that that a1c
and glucose independently contribute to
a1c variation
there are many other proposed
contributions to a1c variation
there's evidence in the literature that
iron deficiency is associated with
differences in a1c independent of
glucose
anemia as well patient age ethnicity
thalassemia thalassemia carrier status
and hemoglobin variants as well
are associated with differences in a1c
what i would like to suggest in the
remainder of this presentation is that
many
of these factors seem to exert their
effect
by altering the red cell age
distribution by altering the mean red
cell age
some of these effects will persist for
instance like hemoglobin variants
but for many of these other effects if
we can estimate
the mean red cell age accurately we
might be able to adjust a1c for this
non-glycemic effect
and end up with a much more accurate
estimate of average glucose
so next i'll describe some common
clinical scenarios
where rbch appears to vary
and have an influence on a1c independent
of glucose
there are a number of different
scenarios the the
the few that i'll discuss are listed
here so let's just start first with
pregnancy
we know in pregnancy that there are
changes in uh red
blood cell production a recent study by
edelson and colleagues in the journal of
clinical endocrinology and metabolism
showed that in a cohort of pregnant
women the average glucose
increased from the first trimester of
the gestation to the to the second
trimester and beyond
and then after birth the mean glucose
decreased
if glucose was the only effect on on a1c
we would
expect the a1c in these in this cohort
to show the same pattern
but what the investigators found was
that the a1c pattern was the opposite
so in the middle point when the glucose
concentration has increased
a1c has actually decreased
this result suggests that the knee red
cell age had decreased in pregnant women
and in fact there's evidence from older
studies here's one study from
richard in uh anesthesiology
a few decades ago showing that the red
cell volume in pregnant women
increases by perhaps about 30 percent
the idea is that an increased rate of
rbc production
will lead to a higher fraction of young
rbcs in the circulation
and that would correspond to a younger
mean red cell age
which would decrease the a1c above and
beyond what the increase in glycemia
would cause another condition that's
associated
with a1c change is is uh is iron
deficiency
here's a study from diabetes care in
2010
measuring the effect of iron and
erythrocode treatment
on a1c in patients with diabetes and
chronic kidney disease
we can see before the iron treatment the
a1c level was 7.4
on average when these these individuals
were iron deficient
after iron treatment the a1c went down
went from 7.4 to about 6.96
on average now during that time the
hemoglobin level rose from 9.7 to 10.5
suggesting again as in the pregnant
situation that there might have been an
increase in red cell production
due to a new supply of iron well when we
see that the
a1c dropped from 7.4 to 6.96
we might have expected the glucose to
rise during that time with the
start to drop during that time the mean
blood glucose actually
actually increased from 9.5 to 9.7
so glucose goes up but a1c goes down
similar to what we saw in pregnancy
and given that the hemoglobin level
increased
this this situation again might be
explained
by a decrease in mean red cell age
associated with increased red cell
production
another condition or another study also
uh reported the
similar pattern for iron deficiency
showing that iron led to an increase
in uh red cell parameters increasing and
red cell count parameters
but was associated with a decrease in
a1c
and this this pattern too would be
consistent with the idea that
iron deficiency would lead to a decrease
in red cell production
and uh that the response would lead to
an independent effect on a1c
another condition that's been that's
been
shown to be associated with a1c
independent of glucose
is g6pd deficiency or glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenation deficiency
which is a mild enzyme disorder that can
be associated with faster red cell
turnover
wheeler and colleagues showed in a large
genetic study
that individuals who who had a
variant an enzyme variant for g6pd
associated with higher red cell turnover
that they tended to have lower a1c
so those the the the leftmost points uh
in the plot correspond to the
individuals with this g6 pd variant
and you can see that their a1c was lower
than for the individuals who did not
have that variance
the situation becomes more complicated
however when
wheeler and colleen considered the
effect of this generic genetic variant
in individuals with different genetic
backgrounds
they looked at 22 other genes that were
associated with rbc traits and with a1c
but did not have any influence on the
risk of developing diabetes
and if we look at those three sets of
points in the black boxes
again the left most point in each box
corresponds to the individuals with the
g6pd deficiency
and they tend to have a lower a1c but
the magnitude of that effect is quite
different in the three groups
and these authors suggest that the other
genes were
modifying the effect so we can see
overall that there may be
many more uh genetic variants and
possibly other clinical conditions
where red cell age is is altered
uh to a degree that will affect
hemoglobin a1c
so i'd now like to move on and provide
some
uh some evidence and rationale for why
it's it's likely that red cell age could
be the
dominant source of non-glycemic
variation in a1c
and suggest that there might be a way to
adjust for this variation
and we'll start by considering the
relationship
between a1c and average glucose in an
individual red blood cell
we think about the a1c level or the
glycated hemoglobin fraction
in a single red cell we can go back
a few decades ago to this the the
discovery of the glycation reaction the
chemistry of the glycation reaction
by frank bond and colleagues what they
found was that glucose
is added to the amino terminus of one of
the beta globe and chains of hemoglobin
and that this reaction is very slow
and it is only slightly reversible it's
basically an irreversible reaction
what that means is the chemistry is very
simple there's no enzyme involved
it's a slow reaction it's not
irreversible
and we can then uh we can then simulate
that reaction and estimate its effect
using simple models of chemical kinetics
so the box shows that the chemical
reaction of hemoglobin
being combined with glucose at a rate
quantified by the
the kg rate constant to form a glycated
hemoglobin
this simple chemical reaction can be
described mathematically
by the equations below the equation in
the bottom right
tells us how to estimate the hemoglobin
a1c fraction
in a red cell that's two days old in
order to estimate
the hemoglobin a1c fraction in a red
cell that's two days old
we need to know what glucose that red
cell has seen what is the glucose
concentration that that red cell has
seen over its lifespan
with the advent of continuous glucose
monitors it's possible to get this
glucose data
and to make this prediction with high
accuracy
so given uh an expression for the
hemoglobin a1c
in a red cell at ht then we need to
figure out how many red cells are there
that are t days old or
t plus one uh or t minus one etc
and we do that by considering the the
full distribution
of red cell ages in the population i
won't go into all the details because
the
the relationship between the population
of red cells and a1c
is somewhat tricky but i'll give you a
glimpse at what this relationship looks
like
one of the reasons is it's tricky is
because the the influence that
glucose has is not straightforward on
red cells of different ages
if we consider the full distribution of
red cells in the circulation
for a nominal patient with a red cell
age of
of 100 days we can think about
which glucose concentrations are going
to affect which red cells
so if we focus initially on the red
cells that are
the oldest red cells in the circulation
those that are 100 days old
they've been circulating for 100 days so
they've seen all of the glucose
concentrations
from the past 100 days but as we
consider
the the younger cells in the circulation
for instance the 50 day old cells
they were not exposed to the glucose
prior to 50 days ago
the only glucose that influences their
a1c level as a glucose
more recently and if we zoom all the way
to the present
the red cells that were producing the
bone marrow yesterday
the only glucose they've seen is just
yesterday's glucose
so what that means is that the effect of
glucose on a1c is weighted by time
the older glucoses have much less of an
effect on a1c
because they're only affecting the a1c
in they're really old red
cells while the more recent glucose
concentrations
are affecting a1c and all of the red
cells
so given given this approach to
studying a1c in single red cells and
then
integrating the effect of the single red
cell a1c over the full population
we can then predict the a1c
for an individual if we have an estimate
of
that person's mean red cell age and we
measure the glucose
i won't go into the details of how
that's done right now but i will show
you
uh an example of of the results
so if we take this this data plotted
here is from a clinical trial of
diabetes
patients who had continuous glucose
monitoring
which enabled accurate measurement of
their average glucose shown on the
x-axis
and a1c measured on the on the y axis
these same individuals six months
earlier had had another set of
measurements which allowed us to
estimate their mean red cell age
so if we assume that only glucose and
red cell age determine a1c and that
nothing else
has any influence we can use the model
that i described previously
to predict the average glucose and then
we can compare our prediction to what
was measured
with the continuous glucose monitoring
so in this case the individuals with low
knee red cell age and high mean red cell
age
would have their a1cs adjusted to match
those that would be expected for someone
with the mean red cell age equal to the
population mean
when we do that adjustment as shown on
the next slide you see that the
average glucose we estimate from the a1c
corresponds
much more precisely is much more
accurate compared to the measurements
the results of this study suggest at
least for this cohort
that mean red cell age and glucose are
the only factors
significantly influencing hemoglobin a1c
the basic idea here is uh
if if hemoglobin a1c is determined only
by glucose and by red cell age
then what that means about our current
clinical approach is that we're
measuring hemoglobin a1c
and then we're assuming that every
patient has the same mean red
blood cell age equal to the population
average making that assumption we're
then able to infer the mean glucose
if we use a method like the one just
described
we can measure a1c as before
but we can actually reverse the
expression
and we can measure the average glucose
using
a cgm device a continuous glucose
learning device
and then we can use the a1c results and
the glucose results
to estimate the mean red cell age and
then in the future
we can use that mean red cell age to
adjust our interpretation of a1c
so here's how this minus glucose monitor
for some period of time
to measure glucose time series measuring
a1c
and then we could plug the glucose data
and the a1c into
this equation and use the model to
estimate the patient's mean red blood
cell age
then in the future when the patient is
no longer using a continuous glucose
monitor
and the patient has an a1c measured we
can then use them all in the reverse
direction
so here's here's what a patient with an
a1c of 6
would be told that their average glucose
is about 131 but if this were a patient
whose mean red cell age
had previously been estimated and was
slightly short
we would know from the model that the
glucose
needed to produce a hemoglobin a1c of
6.1
in this case would correspond to a much
higher glucose
but we've tried this approach in some
public data sets and we found for
instance
uh here's here's an example of a patient
who did have mean red blood cell age
estimated at 45 days
and then a1c of 8.1
the standard regression formula would
have
provided an estimated average glucose of
186
but using the method described here we
estimated that the glucose actually had
to be much higher 209
in order for these young red cells to
have become 8.1
glycated we had independent glucose
measurements available
that showed that in fact this patient's
average glucose
was 210 much much closer to the
the mean red cell age adjusted a1c
than the unadjusted a1c
over a a set of four
cohorts of subjects this method has
appears to be much more accurate than
current regression
approaches the the results here
are comparing the errors in
estimated glucose using the current
method shown in red
and uh a mean red cell age-adjusted
method
shown in blue a perfect estimate of
average glucose
would have an error of zero shown by uh
the perfect arrow and the black line
there at
an ag estimation error of zero
because there's some error in the
hemoglobin a1c measurement
the uh the the in in reality the perfect
error is not achievable and due to
analytic error
an error about three is all we could
hope to achieve
and we can see that those blue boxes
which represent the
performance of the mean red cell
age-adjusted method come pretty close to
doing as well as we can
expect given a1c analytic variation
so this method shows chose promise for
helping us
adjust for non-glycemic variation in a1c
and producing more accurate estimates of
glucose
there are other methods in development
uh different from the one i've described
here
and and they are promising as well it's
it's it's hoped
i'm i'm hopeful that some point in the
near future patients will be
able to benefit from these methods
one last point i want to make though is
that these methods for
improving the accuracy of hemoglobin a1c
by instead of as we currently do
instead of uh assuming what the the
patient's mean red cell ages
so uh that's that's crossed out here
instead of assuming the red cell age
if we measure an a1c initially we can
we can infer that patient's mean red
cell age and then in the future we can
adjust subsequent a1cs
for the effect of red cell age and
provide a more accurate average glucose
but as we can see from this approach in
order to take advantage of these
adjusted a1cs
we'll have to measure a1c twice once to
estimate the mean red cell age and then
in the future
when we want to estimate glucose as a
result of these two measurements
the uh analytic error in a1c becomes
even more
important to reduce um and
it's it's exciting as as
may you may have seen in the first
presentations from this series that the
the accuracy of a1c assays has improved
significantly
over the last years this table here is a
recent survey
published by the ngsp and it's exciting
to see that there are some a1c
assays with coefficients of variation
they're actually below one percent
which is terrific even lower would be
better but this is tremendous
improvement
there are other assays with mean biases
that are
are very close to zero one shown here
with the mean bias of 0.03
and then there are some assays which
combine very low bias
with very low cv and these
these uh these performance
characteristics are important
because for instance if if the the error
in the a1c assay were
two percent if the coefficient of
variation were two percent
then for a patient with an a1c of 6
the true value of a1c could be anywhere
between 5.76 to 6.24
and for a1c of 7 the true value due to
analytic error could be anywhere from
6.72
to 7.28 in the case of an a1c of 7
that potential analytic error would mean
that the average glucose estimate
could be wrong by 5 or 10 milligrams per
deciliter which which as we've seen
previously
is quite significant so i just
uh to sum up what i've discussed i hope
i've shown you first of all
that rbch can certainly alter
uh hemoglobin a1c independent of glucose
and secondly that's important to to
think about because there are many
clinical scenarios where rbch may be
altered
and lastly i hope i've i've persuaded
you that rbc age variation might be the
dominant
source of non-glycemic variation in a1c
and maybe sometime in the future if we
can adjust for this non-glycemic
variation
due to rbc h variation we'll end up with
an even better
estimate of average glucose and a1c
which is already a terrific clinical
test
may be even more useful for patients and
physicians
be happy to answer any questions in the
question and answer session
thank you
thank you dr higgins i'm going to talk
about the importance of variant
detection and hemoglobin a1c
measurement now due to the covet
pandemic most of us
have had some time where we've worked
from home
teleworked and we haven't been able to
go to conferences
that's why this is a video conference
and like many of you i'm sure
we're all looking forward to when we can
attend
a meeting in person i'm just hoping
that i do not end up when i'm flying to
the conference
in a situation like this where the pilot
comes on and says
this is your pilot speaking i'm working
from home today
so long before there was a global covert
pandemic there was a global diabetes
pandemic
this slide from a paper published in
2005 shows on the vertical axis the
years
on the horizontal axis the affected
population in millions
and 2005 they estimated there were
slightly over
200 million people in the world with
diabetes
and the prediction was by 2030 there
would be
approximately 350 million
so what has happened in the last 16
years since this was published
well the latest data from 2019 from the
idf
international diabetes federation and
they estimate
that in 2019 there were already
463 million people in the world with
diabetes
and by 2030 they project
579 million that's well over half a
billion people
with diabetes so with that background in
mind let's
talk a little bit about hemoglobin and
just
a brief background about hemoglobin
it is made up of four globin subunits
and in healthy adults hemoglobin
consists
predominantly 97 is hemoglobin a
which has two alpha and two beta chains
hemoglobin a2 is about two and a half
percent
and hemoglobin f or fetal hemoglobin is
0.5 percent
and the difference is the the um they
all have alpha chains but
a2 and f have delta and gamma chains
respectively
now these percentages change obviously
in the presence of a hemoglobin variant
so to date the 1397 hemoglobin variants
have been identified
but the most common ones by far are
hemoglobin
s c d and e and
this slide shows the distribution of the
common hemoglobin variants
thalassemia is shown in green
hemoglobin s which is the most second
most common
uh is in in orange predominantly in
africa
and the mediterranean region then
there's hemoglobin c
which is uh in west africa and
um hemoglobin e in purple which is
predominantly in
asia now because of travel
and and and migration um the actual
distribution is a little different so
for example
shown here is hemoglobin s the red dot
are where hemoglobin
s is and you can see in addition to
africa
there's a lot of hemoglobin s in north
and south america
as well as europe
now with that background in mind let's
talk about glycated proteins and the
definition of glycation
it's the non-enzymatic addition of a
sugar
to a minor groups of proteins and this
was first described in the food industry
more than a hundred years ago
by maylord and this nice juicy steak
the outside of the steak beautiful
color is due to glycation
now in humans probably
all proteins get glycated certainly most
of them do
but for convenience since we can easily
draw a blood sample
we actually measure glycated hemoglobin
and the analyte measured most frequently
in the world is hemoglobin a1c
which is hemoglobin specifically with
glucose
shown in pale blue attached to the
n-terminal
of the beta chain
and hemoglobin a1c is very very widely
used i'm just going to briefly go
through the main clinical values it's
used to monitor
long-term glycemic control it's used to
adjust therapy
if it changes by more than 0.5 percent
clinicians adjust the patient's
treatment
it's used to evaluate new medications
for diabetes
it's used now to diagnose diabetes since
2010
and if very importantly it's a measure
of the risk
for the development of microvascular
complications
just briefly to go into the analytical
methods so it was first identified
in 1968 by samuel rebel
and then in 1978 assays became
commercially available
in 1988 the american diabetes
association the ada
recommended routine monitoring
currently there are more than 250
hemoglobin a1c
assay methods but these can be
conveniently divided into two general
principles the first
is charge difference so the separation
of the glycated from the non-glycated
hemoglobin
occurs based on differences in charge
and these are capillary electrophoresis
and hplc
the second principle is differences in
structure
between the glycated and the
non-glycated
and the categories include
borinate affinity chromatography
immunoassays
and more recently enzymatic assays
i'm going to for the rest of my talk
focus only on the charge differences
so this is the principle of capillary
electrophoresis
you have a very narrow capillary
that is connected to a positive and
negative charge you have a
very high power supply
and the
hemoglobin a1c separates from hemoglobin
a
and this is seen by a detector i'm going
to show you examples of a tracing so
this would be a capillary
electrophoresis this is what
you would see if you ran one and you can
see hemoglobin a0 which is
non-glycated hemoglobin a is the peak in
pink
hemoglobin a1c is the blue peak here
and there's also hemoglobin a2 which as
i mentioned is the second most common
hemoglobin
which can be separated here and then the
instrument quantifies them
and you can read the percentages of the
different peaks
hplc is similar
separation of hemoglobin a0 from
hemoglobin a1c
and you quantify the peaks
and the difference being with hplc you
can see the baselines
not quite as smooth as capillary
electrophoresis
and also there's no hemoglobin a2
separated
so let's talk about the influence of the
hemoglobin variant on the hemoglobin a1c
result
and i'm going to divide this into two
different
groups so if there's a variant it may
interfere
with the hemoglobin a1c measurement
itself so this is an analytic
interference happens in the instrument
the patient's hemoglobin a1c
reflects their mean glucose the second
category
is where the variant may influence
interpretation
that means it actually changes the
hemoglobin a1c
value so that it no longer accurately
reflects
the mean glucose concentration
so let's talk about the briefly the
analytic interference
so it's very important to realize that
one cannot measure hemoglobin a1c in
individuals
with homozygous hemoglobin s or c
because there's no hemoglobin a they
have two hemoglobin s
chains and so there's no hemoglobin a
obviously there's no hemoglobin a1c
however one can measure hemoglobin
a1c accurately in most heterozygous
hemoglobin variants if you use the
appropriate assay
and how do you find the appropriate
assay how do you choose
we can get all of that information from
the ngsp website
i'm just going to briefly give you an
example of what you can find on the ngsp
website
what i've shown here i know this is a
very busy slide but i just want you to
get the concept
um the left column is is the
the different methods and then the next
four columns
are the common heterozygous variance
and this shows whether that variant will
interfere with that method
so everything that's in yellow means yes
there's an interference
you shouldn't use that method for
that variant and capillary
electrophoresis
is shown near the bottom and you can see
none of the common variants
interfere
but it's important to be aware that many
individuals with these heterozygous
variants such as
hemoglobin as which is sickle cell tray
ae
thalassemia etc have no idea that they
have the condition
and you can usually identify these
so-called silent variants
if you use a separation method based on
charge that is capillary electrophoresis
or hplc
this shows an example of capillary
electrophoresis
in an individual heterozygous for
hemoglobin
s so you can see the s peak
in gray and the a peak a 0
in pink
so you can clearly identify the variant
now let's talk about if the variant
interferes with interpretation
you've heard a very detailed and very
elegant
discussion of erythrocyte lifespan
i just want to highlight um a couple of
points
any hemoglobin variant that
significantly alters the red
blood cell lifespan will alter
hemoglobin a1c
and that is clearly evident from
dr higgins's talk
and in this situation the hemoglobin a1c
value
will not accurately reflect the
patient's
mean or average glycemia so let's do
a simple
calculation
everybody's taught that the red cell
lifespan is 120 days
but like most analytes there's
presumably a range in healthy
individuals and actually dr higgins has
shown that
so uh you know your sodium's 135 to 145
so there's a range it's not 140.
so let's assume and i don't know that
this is real but let's assume the red
cell lifespan is 120
plus minus 10 days if the
individual has a hemoglobin a1c of 7
with a lifespan of 120 days if their
lifespan were 110
days the hemoglobin a1c would be point
four percent
now this means that the target for
treatment
of somebody with diabetes is seven
percent
so if the red cell life spans 110 the
clinician would think this patient is
doing very well
conversely if the individual has a
lifespan of 130 days
the hemoglobin a1c would be 7.6
and the clinician would increase the
therapy in that patient
even though the patient would have the
same average glucose concentration
as the
individual who has seven percent with
120 day lifespan
so it's important to detect atypical
hemoglobins
and i'm just going to briefly describe a
study that that we performed
where we evaluated the medical added
value of capillary electrophoresis
and compared it to immunoassay for
hemoglobin a1c measurement
and we determined the prevalence of
ovarian hemoglobin
in this population during routine
hemoglobin a1c
measurement and this
any hemoglobin a1c profile that was
flagged as atypical by the forester
software and the capillary
electrophoresis was investigated further
and this study was conducted in february
of 2017
at empath reference lab in south africa
a brief overview of the results
there were 2 364 individuals
who had hemoglobin a1c measured during
that month
this was normally 92 percent
and atypical hemoglobins were seen in
187
people or eight percent of the
population
the most common abnormality was
decreased hemoglobin a2
and this can be seen clearly in this
tracing here
this was identified in 145 people or 6.1
percent of the total population
and just briefly the the main causes of
low hemoglobin a2
are iron deficiency anemia which
increases hemoglobin a1c and alpha
thalassemia which decreases hemoglobin
a1c
the second most common abnormality was
increased hemoglobin a2
this is an example of a tracing of a
patient with increased hemoglobin a2
this was much less common occurred only
in 15 or
0.6 percent of the population so it was
only one tenth as common as
uh decreased a2 and the main causes of
increased hemoglobin a2
are beta thalassemia
megaloblastic anemia due to b12 folate
deficiency
hyperthyroidism and antiretroviral
therapy and this
these conditions change the hemoglobin
a1c
so it's important to identify these
people because the hemoglobin a1c does
not
indicate what the average glucose
concentration is
so the conclusions of this study that in
this
patient population the prevalence of
hemoglobin abnormalities is eight
percent
all these abnormalities were identified
by capillary electrophoresis and
obviously none was detected by
immunoassay
and the added medical value is that
these 187 individuals identified
should receive special attention from
clinicians
and clearly the hemoglobin a1c
concentration may not reflect the
average glucose
so what happens if the hemoglobin
variant does not alter red cell life
span
there was an important question that we
asked is the extent of glycation of the
beta chain
of a variant hemoglobin for example
hemoglobin s
the same as that of hemoglobin a now
this is obviously an important question
and so to answer this
we performed a study where we measured
by mass spectrometry
the extent of glycation of the beta
chain
of hemoglobin s and
compared it to glycation of hemoglobin a
and this shows an example of a mass
spectrum
of hemoglobin as
you can see the alpha chain which is not
important for the purposes of this
discussion
there's the beta chain of a and here's
the beta chain of
s very nicely separated and then you can
see all the glycated species
glycated beta s
glycated beta a and so what we did was
we quantified these and
that's shown in the next slide here
for 41 individuals where you can see
the extent of glycation of the beta
chain of a in
gray and the beta chain of s in black
and you can see that for most of these
individuals
um the
beta chain of s is
glycated slightly greater than that of a
and we quantified this so the total
glycated
hemoglobin as the sickle
tray individual was two percent greater
than hemoglobin a which would be a
normal hemoglobin
so for example if hemoglobin a has
hemoglobin a1c of six
an individual with hemoglobin as would
be 6.1 percent
now i mentioned that a change of 0.5
is deemed to be clinically significant
so it's very unlikely that this would
have
any clinical significance for a patient
all right it's time to summarize i think
it's important that the clinician should
be notified
if a hemoglobin variant is seen because
often with
heterozygous variants neither the
patient nor the doctor knows
hemoglobin a1c can be measured
accurately
in the vast majority of subjects with
common hemoglobin variants
and any hemoglobin variant that
significantly alters red cell life span
will alter hemoglobin a1c
and finally for if the hemoglobin a1c is
less than 4
more than 15 or discordant with the
clinical assessment
it should be repeated by different
hemoglobin a1c method
and finally i would just like to
acknowledge
uh marita duplicity and the staff at
ampat national reference lab in south
africa
for participating in the study thank you
very much
well thank you dr saks and dr higgins
for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question
is for dr higgins of all the factors you
mentioned that affect red
blood cell survival which of the hba1c
testing methodologies
used today would help identify those
problematic patients experiencing these
factors
and why
thanks jen for the question i would say
that a method that can
both identify the presence of hemoglobin
variants and quantify
the amount of variant present would be
most useful in
identifying people who might have
altered mean red cell age
i know that hplc and electrophoresis
would work and when i say variants i
also
include a2 and f which are not i guess
uh technically variants but identifying
altered levels
of hemoglobin a2 as dr sachs described
might help identify iron deficiency uh
and thalassemia trait
and identifying altered levels of fetal
hemoglobin might help identify
for instance people with altered
erythropoiesis
thanks thank you dr higgins
our next question is for you dr saks as
chairman
of the ngfp what kinds of hp a1c
questions do you get asked from
clinicians
the most common question i get from
clinicians and i get this
from clinicians all over the world both
when i give presentations or in emails
is i have a patient so the
clinician says i have a patient and the
hemoglobin a1c
concentration is not consistent with the
clinical
situation and the glucose measurement
what what what is what are the possible
[Music]
explanations
and what would you say to to those
clinicians who asked that question so so
the approach that i
suggest is the first thing would be to
measure hemoglobin a1c by a different
method
to make sure that if there's an
interference in the hemoglobin a1c it's
not
specific for a certain method and if
the result is still the same then one
would
[Music]
suggest that the clinician looks for a
hemoglobin variant which can be done
by hemoglobin electrophoresis or
capillary electrophoresis
and also it's possible to look at
long-term glucose concentration that's
independent of hemoglobin
and red cells by looking at glycation of
albumin and this can be done
either by measuring glycated albumin
itself
or by fructosamine which has been used
for many years so
that's that's the approach i suggest
perfect
thank you dr saks and another question
for
dr higgins what prompted you to go down
the road to investigate the differences
between hva1c
and estimated average glucose and why is
this important
and by the observation
that i think my initial interest was
driven by the the observation that
there's a lot of non-glycemic variation
in a1c
and uh we initially just wanted to
quantify the effect
of uh red blood cell age variation and
we were surprised
to discover that it seemed to be
explaining quite a large fraction
of the non-glycemic variation and i'd
say
it's important first of all to to
understand this source
of of uh variation the interpretation of
a1c
as a marker of average glucose and
hopefully at some point we'll we'll be
able to use this understanding to
improve the a1c based estimates of
average glucose as well
thank you dr higgins we have another
question for dr saks
now that the ngsp has standardized hba1c
across
vendors what do you see are the next big
hurdles for the ngsp and patient care
well standardization is only part of the
issue the
this requires obviously ongoing
monitoring and
working with manufacturers but in
addition
as was clearly indicated
in dr higgins talk both from
the complications trial
which showed a small change in
hemoglobin a1c
can result in a big change in
complications is that
and and also the uh effect of
change in red cell age is the uh
accuracy so
accuracy is critical um so the goal is
to
reduce cv as much as as possible
and to in addition to try to minimize
bias
thank you dr saks and we've got some
other questions coming in i believe this
is for dr higgins but feel free either
of you to
to answer
okay
okay i'm sorry i had some technical
issues can you hear me
i will repeat the question uh dr higgins
how is mean rbc determined today
way to determine mean red there's no
easy and accurate way to determine mean
red cell age today
the gold standard methods involve
collecting blood from an individual and
labeling the cells
uh reinfusing them and then collecting
follow-up samples
every so often it's very time intensive
and expensive
and uh the accuracy is a bit unclear
so unfortunately there's no there's
currently no good way to measure the
mean red cell age
i am hopeful that if we can calibrate
this method using uh
basically using glucose as a label and
a1c is a readout of the
the concentration of the label i'm
hopeful that that will
uh if calibrated provide a an easy and
accurate estimate of mean red cell
age
thank you dr higgins the next question
we have
is there any evidence of high a1c that
may not be linked to diabetes
yeah that's that's a good question as
well and there certainly
are some circumstances where individuals
can have
uh very long mean red cell age so long
in fact that the a1c
can reach above the six and a half
percent level
and in that case those people would be
might be told that they have diabetes or
pre-diabetes if a little bit lower and
in fact
it could entirely be a result of altered
red cell age
and in those cases having an independent
measurement
of of glucose directly would be quite
helpful
i'll also add that
there are causes of of
increased glucose that are actually
termed secondary diabetes so in essence
any increased glucose is termed diabetes
but these are not what one would
typically think of as diabetes so for
example certain hormonal conditions like
cushing's disease with very very high
steroids cortisol or even a patient who
takes
high dose steroids for
[Music]
several weeks to month can increase
hemoglobin a1c
thank you both of you it looks like we
have time for one more question
this one is a it's got a few parts to it
what is the variability at rbc lifespan
over time
and wouldn't cgm be needed periodically
to adjust the model
also what is the advantage of hba1c
over cgm considering the variables for
red cell lifespan
isn't constant and the last part do you
foresee
the cgm will be incorporated into the
screening
monitoring methods for diabetes in the
future
so i can start i think a number of
interesting and important questions
there
so first as far as the variability of
rbc lifespan
i'll say we don't uh know with
confidence
what that really is because as i said
rbc age and lifespan are difficult to
measure
i will say that using the method i
described uh
we do have some evidence that at least
in in healthy
uh people and in people with with
well-controlled chronic illness it does
seem to be
stable uh meaning that we've estimated
mean red cell age
in individuals and uh you know up to two
two or three years later it seems to be
fairly stable
of course that that would not hold for
anyone with an acute illness or
more serious condition and then as for
the question about whether
uh continuous glucose monitoring should
be used
uh you know instead of a1c i guess i
think the the
the benefit of a1c is a non-fasting
one-time blood test is is uh
is is huge and you know for a screening
situation i don't think we'll ever use
cgm which would would require monitoring
somebody
for at least a day if not multiple days
i i do think in the future that cgm
could be incorporated as maybe a
follow-up test
if the a1c is is indeterminate or
confusing
then cgm could be used in some
situations to help resolve discrepancies
thank you so much i can just add okay i
just want to add a a quick comment
um that cgm does have several
limitations
uh particularly cost
some countries uh in the world find
hemoglobin a1c even expensive
cgm's much more expensive it requires
a very large it's labor-intensive
patient has to insert a needle under
under the skin
and so there are lots of issues with cgm
it's it's not just you know drawing a
blood sample and then getting a result
thank you dr sachs and dr higgins do you
have any final comments for our audience
today
so i can i'll just say that i think the
accuracy of the a1c assays
as i mentioned in my presentation that
is going to continue to be
really important and i think the ngsp
has done a terrific job
uh driving uh improvement and assay
accuracy
that's that's exciting for a number of
reasons for patients and physicians
and and and i also mentioned that you
know as i indicated in one of my slides
hemoglobin a1c has become such an
important component of
management of diabetes that uh
and and there's a huge huge huge body of
literature
um justifying its use and
and its role and complications and the
the targets for treatment
um i i don't anticipate that hemoglobin
a1c will disappear in the very near
future and there doesn't appear to be
any um easily measurable marker
that's uh likely to appear in
in the near future that will supplant
hemoglobin a1c
well thank you again to our speakers dr
david sachs and dr
john higgins for your time today and for
your important research
we would also like to thank labruts and
our sponsor sevia for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speakers via the contact
information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye